in East Jakarta this is whoosh a new
high-speed Railway connecting Jakarta
and the City of Bandung in West Java
district
modernization and efficiency of our mass
transport system which is
environmentally friendly and integrated
with other modes of transport
the 142 kilometer rail line Cuts travel
time from around three hours to under
one hour
the train can reach a top speed of 350
kilometers an hour
in September authorities began public
Trials of the train ahead of its
official launch we have already reached
padalarang station which would normally
take two to three hours the seat is
comfortable it's just like sitting on
the sofa at home
the project which is mostly funded by
China cost more than 7 billion dollars
to build after significant cost overruns
due to construction delays jakarta's new
High-Speed Rail is an important part of
beijing's belt and road development
project China will soon celebrate the
10-year anniversary of the initiative as
some experts raise concerns about
growing debt risks
some say the high-speed Railway is a
burden for Indonesia's budget
the future of this project
I think similar to other Chinese
projects in other countries Seaport in
Sri Lanka in Pakistan and African yeah
the project
not fishable
then the company could not pay the debt
then collapse
there is no way to finance again this
project
president Jokowi has acknowledged some
of the criticisms of the project noting
that experience is expensive but
valuable and the country should be
enthusiastic about developing its
transport links
the government is planning to extend the
Rail Project into East Java
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Beijing